okay so we have to noon everyone
I guess it's my time to start or is it
not okay so my talk is about rust for
sickest as developers and the idea here
is to give C++ developers a jump start
to the rust programming language
comparing contrasting the languages so
that it's easier to kind of get into if
you are a super fast developer has have
some background in in C++ so my name is
Pavel I'm a developer trainer author I
have some books that I've written
they're all available online like I
always say please buy them make me money
so please do that I authored a few tools
that are part of my github repository I
have some blogs which you can read if
you again have trouble sleeping or
something and I've also also some
courses for plural sign and so the idea
here is to introduce rust again with a
mindset of superstars giving some coding
examples and so we'll discuss briefly
what's rust is and the main kind of
thinking behind rust and how it differs
and how it very similar to C++ in some
regards and hopefully are just going to
show you some code which should make
things easier to understand now one
disclaimer I'm not a rust
expert I'm also learning rust as we go
along so maybe not all the code I'm
going to show you see is idiomatic rust
or the best rust possible but it should
be close enough because the code is not
is not going to be very complex so what
is rust so if you open the rust a
website it has some kind of slogans or
sort of marketing slogans to lure
developers to go and work with rust so
rust is blazingly fast and memory
efficient ROG rusty rich type system and
ownership model guarantees memory safety
thread safety and rust has great
documentation friendly compiler with
user mess with error messages that are
actually you
full and top-notch dueling so this is
part of the advert advancements on the
rust website so if you read that you say
well sounds like the perfect language to
me let me have that
I want that and plenty of it and so one
thing so we'll see several things in
this session some of them actually make
this advertisement correct some of them
maybe not so much but trust is a
language in progress and the ecosystem
is is growing but it looks promising I
mean that looks pretty good
so let's start with some general terms
and compare C++ to rust so it's easier
to kind of talk about them in more
detail later on so we have primitive
types in C++ we have primitive types in
rust rust also has associated functions
or sociated methods with these primitive
types Association methods is comparable
to static methods in C++ so if you think
about it what is static really it means
nothing
associated methods looks a little bit
better so we have primitive types who
have structures and so in C++ you have
struck and class keyword which are
essentially the same in rust it said
well why do you need two keywords just
keep one and that would be struct and
then we have enumerations so enumeration
C++ we have enumerations in rust however
rust enumerations are actually very very
powerful and much more powerful than C++
and I'll show you an example later on
and the actually can implement a union
in fact they're actually more like
unions than just simple enumerations
even even though they can be that as
well so in C++ you can have pure future
functions as part of the class sort of
an interface and so you can have that in
rust as well it's called trait and again
these terms are different from
lexicographical point of view so it's
important to introduce them so we have
inheritance in C++ inheritance form
interfaces and inheritance of
implementation rust has a limited
support for inheritance only for
creating
here in tents it does not support
inheritance of implementation all the
traits can have default implementations
so this is kind of mitigated of sorts
we have support for runtime polymorphism
I'm not talking about compile time
polymorphism using templates which is
available in C++ but it's not available
in rust because of some things or rules
which I'll share a later on who having
C++ attributes we are which are kind of
a closed set of things we can say about
something in rust attributes are also
implemented by trait and actually it's a
it's their extensible can create our own
attributes and implement attributes on
various types and we have templates in
C++ they are called generics in rust and
it's not just a different name it's a
different approach so in C++ it's mostly
duck typing so if you have some template
that has a call to a function foo if
that class or type has accidentally
function foo the correct parameters that
will compile all fine but if it doesn't
then it won't so we can't really know up
front what you expect in some of these
templates and so this is some what is
going to be mitigated in C++ 20 with
concepts but rust already takes one step
ahead to mitigate that and make this
always safe so that's some kind of
introduction the most I think difficult
part in grabbing with rust is the idea
of the ownership model this is the
fundamental change and I think this is
the kind of the challenge from when
moving from C++ or trying to understand
rust based on what you know in C++ so in
C++ you can have a single owner or a
shared ownership we are various types
such as the shirt pointer you can have a
single owner with the unique pointer but
really you're not in false in any way
you can make mistakes for example you
can pass a row pointer to some function
and then function may decide that it is
going to keep that pointer for late
which is of course a bad idea because if
you intended to share that pointer you
should have passed along a shared
pointer but the compiler cannot enforce
that and you're left on your own in rust
you have a single owner and model at the
bases and that's explicit and we'll see
that this is something that allows the
rust compiler to make sure we don't make
mistakes
we don't make sort of maybe silly
mistakes but they're not so silly when
you have a very large system on your
hands
and so from C++ point of view the
developer has to know what it's doing
that's always being the case I'm not
saying it's good or bad I'm just saying
this is the way it is this is the
expectation the expectation from the CSS
developer it is to do the right thing in
rust the compiler is the one responsible
for making sure we don't mess things up
and so we have something called the
board checker in rust which is
responsible to make sure that we don't
do things in the wrong way and I'll show
you a few examples in a moment
and so in C++ we have assignments and
copy construction and by default when we
assign one value to another they're just
being copied the copy constructor or our
assignment operator is being called
unless we have an hour value on our
hands or use the the move function and
stuff like that in rust this is kind of
the opposite so the model is everything
is first moved so if you assign
something you move the ownership for one
variable to another variable and so the
previous variable now has nothing if you
try to use it it will not work and I
mean the compiler will tell you that you
can do that because it's no longer the
owner of the object and so what you
typically do you borrow the reference to
the object to do some stuff with it and
then kind of return it to the owner so
typically you're going to borrow
references and of course the borrowed
checker will make sure you're not making
him stay for example you cannot borrow
something and out leave there's
something that you referencing that can
never happen the compiler will make sure
of that
in C++ it's your responsibility if you
take a reference to something so you not
use it after that something may already
be dead so enough talk let's see some
code so here is a very very simple
example here is the C++ example we have
a vector v1
that's initialized with three values
nothing very spectacular there and then
I'm assigning that or copy constructing
that to V 2 and V 3 and because V 1 is
an L value in terms of in C++ terms then
the copy constructor is going to be
activated and once we run this what we
get is really three distinct vectors
they have no connection to one another
each one is independent we have a deep
copy going on here with these vectors
each one can be developed further and
it's on its own it's unconnected to the
other vectors if you try the same thing
in ruff this is what it looks like and
so in rust we declare variables using
the let and statement by the way you'll
notice that in rust all the key words
are as short as possible so a function
is FN and let is very short so rust is
really about keeping things short and
what we see here is that we are
initializing v1 using a macro in rust
when you see the exclamation point it
means a macro it's not the same as the
seen macro don't worry about it's not
some kind of copy-paste that the
preprocessor does and then you'll have
to deal with the aftermath it is
something different but for our purposes
it creates a vector with three numbers
notice I didn't have to specify the type
rust always or at least does a lot of
work to infer types automatically but it
is statically typed so it's nothing like
some variant or some JavaScript object
that can grow this is exactly a Veck of
a I 32 which is the 32-bit integer in
rust and so now when we do something
like laked v2 equals v1 we actually
transfer ownership from v1 to v2
so now v1 holds nothing and then the
third instruction trying to move v1 to
v3 will actually fail but it will fail
in compiled time and so we get this nice
error from our rust compiler so notice I
mean if you ever done C++ development
and using templates and you have a
compilation error good luck with that so
you're looking at the error and it's
kind of maybe 200 characters long and
those braces the triangular braces are
all over the place and you not not sure
what you have to do here
the raskin Peyer is really different and
I think that statement from the
marketing slogan at the beginning is
completely correct so it says hey Val
you moved here in line 17 values here
after move and so you getting a very
clear error message and in many cases
the Russ compiler will also provide
suggestions of how to fix that and so
really I think I'm very happy with the
rest compiler because it really helps me
to do the right thing and so how can we
fix that so one way to do that is use a
specific method on Veck which is called
clone and that's because vac implements
a trait or you can think of that as an
interface or an attribute which is
called clone which has a clone method
and it really just makes a copy of
itself and so now v2 is a completely
independent copy of the vector same goes
for v3 and then we get to the same place
as the C++ code this just to give you an
idea of what the expectation in Roscoe
so assignment is really moving it's not
copying unless you call a specific
method if of course that method exists
that's a very simple example to start
with so here's another simple example
that shows you borrowing in action so
let's say I'm writing this function so
this is a function in rust you can see
that functions are declared with the F
and keyword give a function name
and then the parameters are given in
this way there's a variable named colon
and the type in this case I'm using the
standard type string and this is
returning nothing so I can just go ahead
and implement that function notice by
the way that the curly braces on the
same line
this is rust good style now most people
like the curly braces on the next line
so I hate it so I love rust because of
that at least all the rest is is just
nonsense but the curly braces are are
the most important thing and so now I'm
in my main function and I want to call
this function and so I'm creating a
string using the associated that is
static method called from and the reason
I'm doing that and not just providing
the just the string using this static
quote is that because it will not
actually give me string with something
else which will not get into so I'm
going to create a real dynamic string
which I can even change later if I
wanted to and then I'm calling greet
name and because I'm passing a name to
the method I'm actually passing
ownership and so this code does not
compile why because on the next line I'm
doing something with name but name is
gone so it's now an empty sort of
pointing to nothing there's nothing
there and so the compiler does not allow
me to have this code so it says look
value moved here and so you're trying to
use it again here you can't do that
that's against the rules and so the
solution to that is fairly simple and
just get need to get used to that and so
here's what I need to do the function
root is not going to get the object
string but a reference to string because
I'm just want to do something without
string and and that's it I'm not trying
to store it anywhere I'm just going to
use that as an input parameter and so in
this case I the call to the greet
functions for passes along a reference
to the string so I have to put that
ampersand in the declaration
the function and in the cold site where
I'm calling the function then can go
ahead a news name just fine so this is a
simple example of borrowing a reference
and using that temporarily and the
compiler will make sure that the
lifetime of the reference is not
outlived the lifetime of the object it
is referencing in this case it's very
simple to see but there are some other
cases which are much more complex let's
see another example where we actually
thank the compiler for not compiling our
code so here is some C++ code which
looks fairly innocent I'm creating a
vector of string then pushing a string
in there and then I look at that value
in v-0 and then just displaying that
then I'm pushing another string and
displaying the previous value again so
this looks innocent enough but if you
try to compile it it compiles just fine
the compiler doesn't care about anything
if you try to run it I try to run it in
on Visual Studio in this case and this
is what I got in a debug build says
something bad has happened there is an
access violation it's an error to get to
a location which has the real address
dddd with many DS clearly that's not a
good idea so if you look at the code if
you're a superstar's developer and think
a little bit something here is
problematic and the problem is maybe not
so easy to spot even though we have only
about four or five lines of code and the
problem is that the second push needed
to increase the capacity of the vectors
it was relocated to another region in
memory and the existing strings were
just copied there and so the previous
reference was now referencing an old
data which wasn't longer there it's just
not there and the compiler cannot really
help me determine and this is
problematic I'm going to heat problems
at runtime
maybe not all the time if I if by chance
there was still room in that vector the
capacity was higher and the reallocation
was not needed then that would work but
then I deployed the application in some
case after adding more more strings and
using this kind of code it will crash so
I'm going to debug these things and this
is no fun it's better if the compiler
can tell me upfront this is a bad idea
so if I try to do that in rust here's
the sort of the equivalent code I'm
creating an empty vector notice the mute
keyword so in rust all variables are
immutable by default so we cannot mutate
and you cannot change them if you do
want to change something you have to add
the mute keyword again it's everything
is shortened this message passed as
possible which again gives the intent
you're opting in saying hey I declare my
intent to make changes to this object
which i think is better than the
opposite most languages take the
opposite stance you can do anything with
a variable and then in C++ you have to
stick a Const in various locations to
say hey I'm promise I'm not going to do
any changes to that particular object
and so I have an empty vector here and
pushing hello and then I'm taking a
reference to v-0 in exactly the same way
as the C++ code and printing that value
and then I'm pushing another value and
printing the previous value as well so
we try to compile that I get another
compilation here that says hey you
borrowed a reference here immutably and
then you change something here so you
mutated something while you have an
immutable reference to the object that's
exactly a data race and because of that
data race the compiler says hey I'm not
going to allow that so the compiler is
of course very conservative because it
may be the case that this vector also
has more capacity in it and maybe that
actually will not crash in runtime but
the RUS compiler is not taking any
chances so it forces the developer
to do things differently to make sure
that a hundred percent that nothing will
bad will happen so of course that means
the as always in programming there's no
free lunch you can't really get
everything so you do need to do some
things differently even if you can
guarantee that that vector will not need
any reallocation in this simple scenario
and so I haven't provided a solution
here yet we'll discuss that yeah so it
will not work in exactly the same way
because once you have a mutable
reference you cannot have any other
references to the same thing mutable or
immutable that's the basic idea if you
have only immutable references you can
have as many as you want because they
can just read the data but once you have
one meter by reference that's it you
cannot have any other references in the
same scope that's the idea here
okay so here's again some brief
comparison from terms known in C++ to
stuff that we that are implemented in
raft and so this model of borrowing may
seem like perhaps a good idea but it
looks kind of limiting because how can I
share an object between multiple
elements maybe multiple threads even
it's not good enough to have just a
single owner so we need something more
and surahs provide this as part of its
standard library so for instance zipless
parts we have unique pointer nick
pointer is very simple something that
allows us to have a single owner to
something that is allocated typically on
a hip and so rust has an equivalent
called box so I can take anything give
it to box : : ooh and that would be
stored on the hip and so the box will
kind of point to that something but
boxes is a bit easier to use the unique
pointer because of a trait the trust
supports you can actually access the T
object implicitly without doing
any special debt or something like this
to get to the underlying pointer so it's
a bit easier to use because this is a
very common thing to do for shared
pointer that c++ provides the equivalent
in rust our RC this is the the single
threaded reference counter and we have a
RC which is the atomic reference counter
so if you need to share an object
between threads you have to use a RC and
that implements certain traits that
allow it safely to move to form thread
to thread so these are kind of the terms
that you can see here which make things
a little easier to understand and so
reference s exists in C++ of course and
as we've seen in rust references imply
borrowing and the board checker will
make sure stuff is done correctly and so
the default in C++ C naught is non cons
if you want to something to be cons you
have to explicitly specify that in rust
this is exactly the opposite everything
is immutable unless you specify a mute
using new keyword that you want
something to change so let's see
something a little bit more complex
perhaps and so let's say I want to do
something like this I want to calculate
the number of prime numbers between some
first and last number and I want to do
that with multiple threads so I'm going
to do a very simple chunking by giving
each thread a range of numbers to work
on and they're going to work on that
concurrently and then give me back each
one will give me it's result and I'll
just kind of add the result up so that's
a very simple relatively simple thing to
do in a multi-threaded world and so how
would I do that in C++ so here's is an
example of how to do that I have a
simple is prime function the justin
knows to calculate whether a number is
prime or not that's a fairly
straightforward and here's the main
function called calc and so called
Prime's we see the number of threads and
the range of numbers for which I would
like things to work and so the idea here
is that I'm going to create several
threads each thread is going to get a
chunk a from and the to to work on which
I calculate here and then it's going to
run in a loop and check each one whether
it's a prime number or not and if it is
a prime number I'm going to push that
into a vector I maintain here now if
you've done any and then of course I
have to wait for the threads to to
finish using the join method and if
you've done any development in fading
you probably realize there's a bug here
it's a very simple bug but you do need
to know how to solve it so the bug is
that the result here the vector is not
thread safe and so if I use pushback
here
that's not a good idea because multiple
threads are going to use pushback on
that same vector and that vector will
probably be corrupted and so if I
compile this code the compiler says okay
you're good to go
everything is just fine and a trying
time I'm going to crash and so even if I
know how to solve that how would I solve
it so I know that in C++ 11 we have
something called the mutex which I can
acquire before I push the value to the
vector and then release afterwards so
here's a better version so I have a
fixed version here that does exactly the
same thing but we have a mutex here and
that mutex is going to be locked here
using a lock guard which is a rye
wrapper that takes ownership of the
mutex acquires the mutex then releases
that at the end of the scope and within
that scope I'm using this method and
this actually solves my problem but
there's something here which is missing
and the missing thing is that how do I
know for sure I actually solved the
problem
so the code compiles I ran it several
times
looks good but who knows maybe in in a
different size vector maybe with
different number of threads something
will go bad and the problem is that this
mutex has no connection to the vector so
the vector is distinct
and the music's is distinct it is my
sense because the supastarz developer to
use them together correctly so in fact
if there is some call to another
function here providing that vector some
other function can take the vector and
do something with it without the mutex
and I'm going to be in trouble again and
there's nothing to enforce that the
compiler has no idea and that's because
the mutex and the data that it's
supposed to protect our distinct
entities and so in rust things are
different
rust also provides a mutex but that
mutex holds on to the data so if you
want the data you actually to tell you
to please miss the mutex give me the
data and so they're actually together so
there's no way simply no way to access
the data without a mutex use the mutex
really is protecting the data so the
model is different so you can't really
make a mistake you cannot provide that
vector of someone else the compiler will
not let you it's not a runtime thing
it's a compile time thing so how would
that look like and so here's some rust
code in Visual Studio code so I didn't
mention that so if you want to get
started with rust you have to install
that of course which is fairly simple
then you probably want to use some IDE
otherwise you'll be writing in notepad
all your life and it's not much fun
notepad or whatever platform you're
working on and and so we just dude your
code is one of those environments or IDE
switch which can work with rust there's
a pretty good extension that knows how
to work with that so here's my is prime
function just to shoot to just get some
more acquaintance with syntax from rust
so noticed I'm completely here the limit
that's the square root of my number and
that would be my limit for the loop
notice the for loop in rust uses really
something like a range so you can use
iterators and stuff like that so in this
case it says from two to
limit including limit that's the equal
here so this is a range and if we if the
number is divided evenly then we'll
return false and we're done with it and
finally here we're writing true notice
there's no return true here I can
actually write return true but it's more
idiomatic grass to just write the result
that you want to return without the
semicolon and so the semicolon in rust
actually means something if you had have
a semicolon means you don't care about
the result if you don't have a semicolon
then this is actually an expression that
returns something and so because I have
to return a boolean here a returning
true is is just fine
and so the code here is a bit more
complex I'm not going to talk about
every little detail here just to give
you an idea of how that works
so if I try to do something like like I
did previously in C++ just saying okay
let me get vector here maybe even with
the mutex but that's dispensable mutex
here and try to do something with the
vector in that if statement it was
simply not compiled compressor and I
can't do that I can't just transfer
ownership to a different thread at first
because there's no guarantee that thread
is going to be alive while that vector
is like maybe the main thread will
terminate before that and that and then
we're going to have a reference to
something that is already gone so the
compiler will not let me make these
silly mistakes and so the fixed version
looks something like this my data is a
new vector but here I have a mutex that
takes that data and so the mutex is the
owner of my data in a sense so the data
is heat is hidden behind the mutex so if
I want to get to the data I have to
actually tell the mutex lock lock means
acquire the mutex please give me
reference to the actual data while the
mutex is locked and when that variable
goes out of scope after I do a push
operation then the mutex is released so
this is the general idea and and at the
end of this loop I want to get to the
actual value again
have to do lock here to get to the
actual vector back and then return the
size of the vector because the purpose
of my function is just to return the
count of primes and not the entire list
in this case and so again notice I don't
have any return statement just writing
something some expression without the
semicolon and so when I compile it and
it compiles fine I am guaranteed I am
confident this code is bulletproof so
it's going to run correctly anywhere
because again the compiler is very
conservative even if there is a tiny
chance this who could fail in some
mysterious situation it will not let me
compile this code okay so let's move on
another thing I want to show you which
is interesting in rust or enumerations
so enumerations the C++ are are fairly
simple just a set of values you can
specify the exact value you can specify
the size of that enumeration whether
that's four bytes or two bites right
bytes and so on but really there's not
much to it this is just a set of values
now in rust enums are are different so
they can be just like the c++ announced
that's not a problem here's the
seasoning name that we've seen earlier
in a Rasta which is practically the same
but in arms can be more interesting here
is the NAM which is a generic enum that
works on two parameters called T and E
here that has two values which in
themselves are really a family of values
so one of them is called okay with some
object and the other air with some other
object and so this is in fact one of the
types in the rust standard library which
is used for reporting errors from
functions so the typical function that
may fail should return result of
something and something so the first
something is what happens if the method
works correctly what the type that is
going to be returned and the second
something is a type
of error we should provide the error
information in case something doesn't
work correctly in the return the actual
return statement in that function are
going to be okay something or something
and so the calling code can look at that
result and in fact methods in Anam so
Ananse can have methods so it's easier
to work with the the result so if I
maybe I want to look at the error maybe
I want to look at the result maybe I
don't care about the error because I'm
pretty sure that's going to be fine so I
can use the something like unwrap and
just take the result and so on so it's
very rich thing to have another one
which is very common is called option
again it's very common to have that as
return type from functions which is very
similar to the C++ 17 optional type
which means either you have something or
you have nothing so if you have
something T will be the something and
the value some something or you have
nothing so we get back the non value
from dhinam so here's a different
example those of you who are old enough
maybe our familiar with the language
called logo anyone program logo at some
point in their lives I did that in some
point and showing logo there's that
thing called the turtle and T today I
have no idea why it was called a turtle
because it was moving sometimes very
fast and it's very unlikely Turtles I've
seen but it is a turtle and nonetheless
and so if I want to model that for
instance here's one way I can do that I
can create any nam to specify what kind
of commands this turtle can can work
with what the things that he can do so
in simplest facts I will have to just
have a set of values and then have some
way maybe some sub structures that
provide the actual data to some of the
commands may be using a union so here we
get that for free so I have a total
command some of the commands here don't
have any parameters such as rotate right
and rotate left some of them have
parameters such as forward and backwards
and even pen color can have another
object that has three fields RG and B
with
shoot which are representing the RGB
values of some color for instance and so
here's hi how I can work with something
like this let's see a turtle so we not
see a turtle really I'm just doing that
from a textual perspective but you
should just imagine a turtle if you've
done logo development then it's really
usually was drawn as a triangle again
not really a turtle but that was the 80s
so so how do i define all these things
so here's the turtle command this is the
same thing we've seen on the slide and
with a minor difference I've actually
created a struct color here to hold the
RGB values as just a distinct type and
not just an anonymous type so pen color
is going to be of type color so I'm just
writing that as part of denim the turtle
itself here is an object called turtle
so we can declare object using the
struct keyword in in rust and what we
declaring are just the fields so we have
four fields here the heading of the
turtle X&Y and the pen color each one
with its own type so to add methods to
the turtle when using the imple keyword
so that's the way to add methods to
types and so we can actually use as many
inputs as we want in various parts if
that makes sense
and so I'm adding here two functions the
first function is called new each
returns a turtle this is something which
is exactly an Associated function
associated method which means it is a
static one because there's no self here
anyway if there's no self in the
parameters this is me this means static
function or associated function and so
this should be sort of a a creator for
turtle objects the name new by the way
is not special in any way you can call
it anything you want but it's very
common to call the construction method
new The Associated method new and so I
used the same idea and so I'm going to
return a turtle here so this statement
actually creates a turtle and
initializing the fields to some values
and again there's no semicolon here
which
means this whole expression is returning
from the function if I put the semicolon
the compiler will say hey that's a
problem because you're supposed to
return turtle and because the salmon
color actually have the unit function at
the unit type which is like void in C++
so that's not good so either you either
use return which is again considered a
bad style when you just return something
from a function or just make the
semicolon go away and now I have that
execute function this is an instance
method because the first parameter is
self which means this is the turtle
itself and because I'm going to do
something that mutates the object I have
to take a mutable reference to that
object and then I'm accepting another
parameter which is the actual command
and so here we can see some of the power
to the pattern matching capabilities of
rust and this is really just the tip of
the iceberg and so I'm using the match
expression to say hey which command is
it if it's rotate right let's just
change the height heading by adding 90
degrees if it's rotate left let's just
turn it left by 90 degrees if it's
rotate with some angle let's use it
notice the pattern I'm getting whatever
value is passed in inside the command
inside the enum instance same thing for
forward I'm getting some distance I'm
doing some trigonometric calculations to
move the x and y of the turtle to the
appropriate location for backwards same
idea in this case I'm calling myself
with forward with minus D so I'm just
using something I already implemented by
calling it and finally for pen color I'm
doing something just assigning the new
color to the point pen color I am
keeping as part of my object so self
here is like this in in C++ and so one
thing I should mention about match that
you must have all the options so you
have to exhaust all the options of this
the expression you're matching against
the
I exhausted everything and there are
other ways to deal with other values
that I don't care about specifically I
can use something like the underscore
which really says whatever else remains
this is what I want to do sort of a
default in a switch statement in a sense
but of course match is much more more
powerful than simple switches you can
see can see already here so now in my
main function I can utilize that so this
is what it looks like I am creating a
new turtle by calling The Associated
method a new and then just using print
turtle which is the helper function
printing the stuff about the turtle and
just executing various commands just to
show that it actually works and of
course I can build that and run that and
we'll see the various states of the
turtle changing as needed
so these are enumerations which i think
is one of the coolest features in rust
and of course pattern matching goes
along with it but pattern matching is
not just for enumerations but it
definitely is a good way to deal with
enumerations
okay let's discuss traits so trait is
another nice feature in rust so traits
is kind of a combination between
interfaces and attributes in rust so we
can declare a trait we can think of that
as a set of methods perhaps that need to
be implemented by types and so you can
have the latest trucks that implement
traits and so these are sort of an
interface and this is the basis for
pulling morphism in rust so you can have
for example a vector of some trait and
then I can just push into the vector of
various objects that implement that
particular trait which is the classic
way of doing polymorphism in C++ just a
different terminology in that case we
can also inherit traits so one trait can
help from another trait it's actually
also is very common in the in the
standard library and in fact some of the
syntactic sugar in rust is based on on
traits which are used in some cases as
attributes
such the debug attribute I have actually
used in this piece of code so if I'm
using the debug attribute here on color
it allows me to then print something
using this particular notation in in a
way that allows or is easy for developer
to see the exact values of the type
without me having to to invest in a
print line sort of implementation for
that particular type and so this is
basing this on a debug trait so this is
a trait used as an attribute okay so
let's see some examples so here's one
example let's say I want to write a
function that accepts a vector of
something and returns the largest item
in that vector and so we see several
things here one of them is that I need
to provide some assurance to the
compiler that this code can compile does
there that there's some chance for this
to compile because if you were to do
something loose in C++ what you see here
is that we the decoding is implying that
these T values have to implement the
greater than operator and so the CSS
compiler when we see something like this
without of course the the extra
notations here will say okay that's fine
I don't care
once you actually use the function I'm
going to check to see whether that
particular type you're using actually
does implement the greater than operator
or not and then we'll see if it compiles
or not Russ takes a different approach
it's more like generics in c-sharp if
you are familiar with that you have to
have these constraints and so without
these partial order plus copy traits the
compiler will fail the code the
compilation who say hey I can't be
assured that all T's that may be coming
to this function implement the greater
than operator there's no way I know that
not every T in the world and maybe every
t that will be invented in the future
will be able to to fit in here and so I
have to say okay the T's I'm allowing
into this function are only those that
implement the greater than operator
which is what partial old or really
defines this is a standard trait from
the standard library and copies needed
as well because we're returning one
value from the actual vector which is
passed by reference and we can't just
return something by reference the
lifetime would be crazy there and so we
need these two traits to be implemented
in fact there are several ways to
specify the other some and newer syntax
in rust 20:18 but it doesn't matter
from our perspective so once we see this
function the compiler knows that every T
that will be accepted to this function
will make the function work for sure and
so that's very different than the duck
typing that we have in C++ for templates
and and I think this is one of the kind
of nasty stuff in C++ and that's what we
have constantly bastarz 20 to try to
mitigate that so if I look at a function
I know what it expects because in this
example if you look just at the
signature of the function without that
those annotations in C++ you don't have
any idea what the function expects what
kind of T's will make the function work
but looking at this you know exactly
what kind of T's will make the function
work so here's just a simple example of
calling a dysfunction for a range of
integers because I 32 implements partial
old and implements copy so this would
work if it wasn't the case the code
would simply not compile and so as I
mentioned the basis of polymorphism in
rust our traits so let me show you a
quick example what that looks like so
here is kind of the classic school like
example here is a trait called shape so
you can think of that as an interface it
has two members one of them is a method
called area notice it has this a self
thingy which means it's an instance
method and it's immutable so it
shouldn't change anything in the object
same goes for s string so this returns F
32 which is like a flow
and this returns the string so this is
just a trait this is just some
definition and I can create as many
implementations as I want for this
particular trait so this is how this
might look like for several shapes so
here's the struct rectangle here is a
struct ellipse here's a struct circle
when we define them we don't specify any
trace for them and then we can start
implementing them using the impel
keyword so I'm saying impel shape that's
the trade for rectangle and now I'm must
implement both functions otherwise my
class is sort of abstract and the
compiler will fail to compile that so in
this case for area I'm just calculating
the area for L string I'm using the
format macro to kind of create a string
based on these formatting parameters and
that's going to be returned notice again
there is no semi semi colon so this is
an expression is just going to be
returned from this function same idea
for others so here's impulse shape for
circle exactly same idea nothing very
special here and the same idea for
ellipse so now I want to use that so I
can create a vector of shape so shape is
our trait and so one of the ways to
specify that is using this dying keyword
which is relatively new and again I want
that to be mutated because I want to add
new shapes and so I have a rectangle
here I'm going to push it and add it to
the shapes a vector same goes for a
circle ellipse and so on and then I can
just go ahead and iterate over them
using the for statement getting a
reference to each of the shapes each of
these shapes is with the variable S and
that's going to be the shape type and
then then I'm just calling that
polymorphically using the virtual
function mechanism behind the covers
which is very similar in the way virtual
functions are implemented in C++
typically so this is just a simple
example to show how how polymorphism
will look like in the classic
object-oriented sense in rust
okay so what about external packages so
we have when you're looking at a
language there's the language itself and
there are the libraries so the libraries
are super important in fact they're
usually much more it takes much more
time to learn the libraries than the
actual language language is very kind of
usually finite what libraries seem to be
kind of just continuing to grow from
version to version and so in some cases
the standard libraries are just not
enough you want to do something that is
out of the scope of the standard
libraries maybe you want to manipulate
images maybe you want to work with XML
maybe it is part of standard way maybe
it's not usually at some point you need
something else and so in C++ if you want
to get something else you have a very
large ecosystem C++ is very relatively
stable and old language there are a lot
of libraries in C++ and we know that we
have the boost libraries which sort of
where the de facto standard for external
libraries because of that 13-year gap or
C++ didn't move an inch and there are
many other libraries out there but how
do you get them how do you know what's
out there and even if you know what's
out there maybe you want to manipulate
images there may be twenty-five
libraries manipulate the images which is
better and so there's really no single
repository that I know of in C++ so if
you're working in the Microsoft
ecosystem you have something called new
get and you get started its life for
dotnet when in fact nuga today supports
c++ as well so you can search for
packages on you get for c++ assuming of
course the author of that package
actually listed that inside NuGet which
is of course nice but again what about
other platforms
what about lobbies that are not part of
nougat not everybody likes Microsoft and
so you actually are left on your own you
can just go ahead and look over the web
and just try to find something rust has
a fast growing ecosystem it's not as
large as C++ for sure
is relatively young language but it is
expanding rapidly there's a package
manager which is built-in it's called
cargo it's the one that's actually
usually building your application and it
knows to do very a lot of things so you
typically don't initiate the Russ
compiler directly you don't do that you
initialize a cargo you tell cargo here
is my project please bill it and there
is a file that tells the cargo package
manager everything he needs to know
about your project and so there's cargo
and you can use crates crates are the
packages in in rust and there's a
repository for that called create dot IO
so that's an official repository where
cargo actually looks for a package when
when you need one so let's say I want to
do something that manipulates images so
here's the crate IO and I wanted to do
something with the PNG files so I'm just
searching from PNG and I'm finding an
exact match here for PNG if I go ahead I
can see here that this is the code I
have to copy and paste into a file
called cargo Tamil which is the
configuration file for cargo and once I
do that so here's my example here once I
do that it goes and automatically brings
this package and all its dependencies
from that creates our your repository
with the correct versions and then just
build that as part of my project in this
case the demo I'm showing here is
allowing me is something I wanted to do
which is created an image of the
Mandelbrot set if you don't know what
the marble said here is a very cool
thing go to Wikipedia and read about it
so I wanted to do that in C++ and I want
to do that in in rust and so here's the
code in C++ and so that the code itself
is not very difficult it's a
single-threaded but the problem was I
needed to use complex numbers because
this is required by the algorithm and
need to use the PNG library so
fortunately complex is part of the
standard
in C++ that was easy enough just include
complex and you're done
but PNG is not and so I actually went to
do web and try to locate some PNG
library in C++ and of course I found
many of them but had no idea what was
good what was not so good
what was cross-platform what was not
rust is cross-platform so maybe I want
my pinja liable to be that so C++ is
closed fast I want to make the pinch
library also use something which is
cross-platform and so luckily in in fact
this is I think pure luck I found a
library in you get a C+ slash library
that deals with PNG I'll actually didn't
check to see whether it's cross platform
or not this will cry me to do some extra
checks because it's not guaranteed any
in any way but at least I found
something which seems to work and so
I've used that library to create a PNG
file here in the safe to bitmap function
by using the code provided by title but
Ike but by the timer which again I feel
very lucky to to have made it so far but
I have no idea of there any bugs here
people like this library or not I really
have no idea not much at least so what
am I going to do in the rust case so in
the rest case let's find that all I did
here I need I needed two things complex
numbers and PNG support and so again I
search in crates I go for complex
numbers and I found that there's this
library that supports complex numbers I
just copied the version and here you can
see that already cargo notice that there
is a newer version and it may be maybe I
should consider upgrading so at this
point I decided not to upgrade I was
just before the session so it's very not
a very good idea to upset the demo gods
just before a talk and so here's the PNG
function so PNG crate again once I build
that cargo automatically got the
dependencies needed from from the web
from the crates are your repository and
that was it and all that's left to do is
just use this functionality and so
here's my
flex numbers and creating some complex
numbers this is the build Mandelbrot
function I'll make this code available
later if you want to look at that but
basically once I have a proper image I
have a save image function here and I'm
using some functions from the standard
library to open the file and stuff like
that but eventually I'm going to use
this encoder that is coming from that
library provided by that create that I
downloaded and so there's a single
repository and in fact there is actually
a very good documentation that is also
true from the investment point of view
so there's something here called
documentation I can open that up and see
examples and all the types and methods
or whatever is provided by that package
so I have a central location which is
very easy to work with and don't need to
hunt for libraries all over the place
this makes it just easier to work and I
feel safer working with something that
is in great sorrow and see how it was
downloaded 200,000 times that must be
good maybe someone actually is using
that so maybe I should use it as well so
I can I have more confidence with that
library and so I wish the plas class
would have something like this as well
okay so let me sum things up a little
bit and again maybe I was kind of
pounding in C++ too much that wasn't my
intention in fact I had some
difficulties working with some of these
demos when I was creating them because
of that ownership model and boring and
stuff like that and and it does make the
developer work a little bit harder but
this I think eventually it is better to
work harder while you're developing and
have a code which hopefully is more
robust and less likely to fail on
clients machine when you kind of
deploying that all over the place so I
think rust has its place and as always
if you want to experiment something just
have to try it out and I urge you to
just try it out there's really no harm
there are many languages coming
all over the place and most of them are
really just changing some syntax may be
adding some small idea but I think Russ
is different it has really a good design
and it does provide something that other
languages don't and so it's maybe it's
fighting C++ on the same space for
native development performance but it
provides productivity so we'll see what
that goes but I think it is an
interesting thing to look at even if
you're not going to use rust you can get
some ideas for your programming efforts
on in other languages I know I did thank
you
[Applause]